I don't know if you're feeling special
right now but you should be you
navigated one of the most challenging
programs of its kind and you succeeded
you worked hard
but that's that all you learned here
you're also taking away some special
qualities unique to Carnegie Mellon what
is it about Carnegie Mellon that makes
it makes us special
and here I'm echoing some what what
Carolyn talked about we're abnormal
atypical and weird that's basically what
you said and I accept those things but I
want to dig a little deeper what is it
that makes Carnegie Mellon special in
fact it's a question I'm often asked and
one that I'm always trying to answer
just last night three different sets of
parents of graduating students conveyed
the same sort of message to me they said
Carnegie Mellon has been great for my
daughter or son my other child goes to
University X and it's just not the same
there's something special about CMU I
don't know what it is but and here's the
part I like the best president Cohen
you're doing a great job maybe I should
just leave it at that and that try to
dissect CMU or to be overly analytical
about your experience here but it's my
responsibility to understand the
university in order to preserve and
nurture that which makes us successful
go up to almost anyone affiliated with
the University including alumni and say
quick name three things which describe
the culture of Carnegie Mellon they're
very likely to say hard work problem
solving and interdisciplinary
collaboration by the way the fact that
you you be likely to hear the same thing
from almost everyone is itself a Birbal
an important characteristic of Carnegie
Mellon we know ourselves well
and we're comfortable in our skins
furthermore as much as we've changed
over the decades in what we teach and
what we do research on in the campus and
its appearance in our prestige these
values the ones I just mentioned these
elements of our culture have not changed
at all
hard work and collaborative
problem-solving or as much at the core
of Carnegie Tech as they are here today
at Carnegie Mellon I would add one more
value which is key and the theme of this
speech and that's innovation but for
this one for innovation it's hard to
tell whether this is a result of the
other three afterall innovation is the
frequent outcome of interest
interdisciplinary problem solving or
whether it stands on its own it's an
interesting question to explore but I'll
leave that for another time today let's
just accept for the moment that
innovation is definitely part of what
makes Carnegie Mellon tick and it's what
I want you to take away from this place
as you leave us and it's a key part of
understanding our specialness innovation
and the results of innovation were all
around you wherever you were on campus
and whatever you majored in or did for
fun
one consequence of our innovative spirit
as a set of unique programs and
activities this extends to our
extracurricular activities as well as
our research teaching and administration
I mean what other group of students
would abuse their bodies in order to
build a structure which basically has no
useful purpose only to tear it down
two days after building it that would be
you and don't even get me started about
buggy who could fit into those things
like less than 1% of the adult
population and the whole purpose of the
special mode of transportation you
innovated is to return to the place you
started from about two minutes ago
assuming you can find four people
willing to abuse their bodies in order
to push you up the hills way to go
Carnegie Mellon that's innovation
actually joking aside booth and buggy
are not just beloved traditions they
really are characteristic of our
innovative drive and our willingness not
to be bound by convention or to be
afraid to challenge current practice
these are powerful traits of which this
university has built more than a century
of path-breaking innovation in education
at the outset of the conferral of
degrees I explained that we have 267
unique degrees an amazing number we've
been a remarkable innovator in education
throughout our history it's a stunning
record and students are very much part
of making that record would have been
and let me give you some highlights to
explain what I'm talking about it's
important that you understand this
Carnegie Mellon granted the first degree
in drama more than 80 years ago the
first academic industrial design program
was created here in 1934 and this year
is the centennial of our School of Music
in the 1940s
Robert Dougherty Carnegie Mellon's
brilliant third president conceived of
the Carnegie plan a venn radical idea
that engineers should learn economics
and other social sciences the humanities
and communication skills it transformed
engineering education here and
eventually everywhere as the rest of the
world followed Carnegie Mellon's lead
and established CIT our College of
Engineering
as a global leader where remains today
the educational of Asia innovations
which have come from Carnegie Mellon
also exhibit our interdisciplinary
approach to problem solving indeed it
was the very creation of these
educational programs where our
interdisciplinary approach was forks
forged
there are several examples of this but
one of the earliest and probably the
most impactful was our business school
through the 1940s business education
largely consisted of rules of thumb
based on practices of existing companies
in 1949 Carnegie Mellon with the support
of the melon family founded its graduate
school of industrial administration for
GSI a since of course renamed the David
eight Emperor's School of Business in
recognition of David's and his wife's
Marlene's extraordinarily generous gift
to the school GSI a focused on the net
new idea that business management should
be based on analysis derived from
mathematical and economic principles
that it should be in that each employ
the insights from the other Social
Sciences in some sense this idea was a
natural extension of the then-new field
of operations research which is which
was created in the United States and the
United Kingdom during World War two but
turning this in the basis of business
management was a major research
undertaking and became the focus the
very core of GSI a the faculty who
founded GSI a and worked there in the
50s and 60s and their students went on
to win an amazing seven Nobel prizes the
effort and GSI a was also highly
interdisciplinary and collaborative
which laid the foundation for CMU strong
collaborative culture that serves us so
well today
every Business School in the world has
adopted or was founded on the GSI a
tempered school model it's hard to
appreciate what a bold innovation this
was 60 years ago or what a huge impact
it had I suppose if we were more brand
conscious at Carnegie Mellon people
would go to business school today to get
their CMU or their GSI a or their temper
instead of getting their MBA kind of
like the way you reach for a Kleenex
instead of a tissue
you get it ask your parents later on
maybe they'll explain it to you that's
how profound what GSI a The Temper
School has done and that's the kind of
innovation I'm talking about at Carnegie
Mellon here we created the first
department of computer science and the
first school of computer science there
are many subfields of computer science
which were created here we invented
human-computer interaction a field which
combines CS psychology and design we
created the first machine learning
department while we can't claim sole
credit for inventing artificial
intelligence or robotics or language
technologies we're certainly among the
pioneers and research in these areas in
a leader in bringing these concepts into
undergraduate and graduate curriculum
all of these programs are the product of
interdisciplinary collaborative research
and educational innovation by our
faculty working with in responding to an
eager and innovative student body in
1970 the School of urban and public
affairs 9 met now the Heinz College was
spun out of GSI a the faculty had the
idea they could apply the analytical
techniques pioneer in the business
school to the challenges of cities and
public policy in general today the hind
college Heinz College is the
unquestioned leader in quantitative
approaches to public policy in recent
years it's applied its interdisciplinary
approach to many educational innovations
often in collaboration with our colleges
creating masters programs in arts
management medical practice management
information systems cybersecurity and
many more and now we have academic
programs which bridge multiple colleges
most of them the first or only of their
kind this is the University of Pittsburg
buzzing us
I knew they'd fly over just at this
crucial moment many many examples of
inter-college collaboration to present
first-of-a-kind and leading academic
programs educational programs one great
example is computational finance which
is created by collaboration of the
mathematical sciences department in the
Mellon College of Science the Statistics
Department in the Dietrich College of
Humanities and Social Sciences and The
Temper School of Business while other
universities have followed our lead ours
is still the only multi-culti college
program and still ranked number one and
there's computational biology which is a
collaboration between computer science
and department of biological sciences
and a typically our Lane Center for
computational biology is
organizationally and physically in our
school of computer science and there are
more examples and more examples and I'll
save you some of them we also have
unique I should get a standing ovation
for that I just saved at least 10
minutes not just unique degree programs
we have unique departments
there's engineering and public policy in
CIT social and decision sciences in a
teacher colleges these aren't just
unique they couldn't exist in any other
university they could not exist in any
other University I suppose that's the
point
I want to make more than any other I
don't think you could appreciate how
distinctive this makes Carnegie Mellon
first of all these educational
innovations could only have happened in
a research university we're not the only
research university but he requires a
research university with faculty deeply
engaged in research and innovation to
produce the kinds of educational
innovations I've just talked about this
rules out by the way 42
of the 4,500 institutions of higher
education in America which are not
research universities we could also rule
out virtually every other country which
with few exceptions are simply to their
universities are simply to hidebound and
traditional to be competitive in the way
I'm describing here and within our peer
group of the top 60 research
universities in North America well let
me put it this way I'll just say that
the deans the provost and I get
quizzical or astonished looks when we
describe to our counterparts some of the
things that we do here which brings you
back to the question so what makes
Carnegie Mellon special here's the best
I can do as a summary statement our
sense of ourselves as members of a
community is that we were all we are all
motivated to bring our best to and be
the best at that which we choose to do
if there's a better way to do it we want
to find it and we will use it we don't
worry if that breaks with convention we
just do it if it's the right thing that
I think many universities are populated
by people who would fit this mold at
least in some level but somehow we're a
university that's largely avoided the
institutional inertia and bureaucratic
protectionism
that tend to burden other places and to
frustrate the pace of innovation whether
you sensed any of this or not you've
flourished here you learned a great deal
in terms of knowledge and skill indeed
you are as well-trained in your fields
as anybody can be but you also have
developed ways of thinking and doing
that sets you apart that you prepare you
for innovation for being architects of
change
you now join a special group of people
who are also alumni of this greatest
institution just underscore my point
Forbes magazine inaugurated so-called 30
under 30 recognition this year 30 people
under 30 years old who in Forbes words
aren't waiting to reinvent the world
eight of those thirty people are
Carnegie Mellon alumni that's where
you're gonna be and it's not about their
grades it's not about the skills they
learn though that is absolutely
essential
it's about this innovative spirit I've
been talking about that's what you are a
product of that's what we want you to
keep in mind every day of your life
after this we're very proud of you and
very proud to welcome you to this group
of alumni this extraordinary group of
alumni and we look forward to watching
you as you create a lifetime of
contributions and innovations
congratulations
you